puisse me limiter dans mes rêves et mes ambitions
était grotesque.
Et inacceptable.
Je les ai donc ignorés.
(Acclamations et applaudissements)
Je me suis mariée.
Et j'ai décidé de ne pas avoir d'enfants.
Et j'ai continué ma carrière pour les Nations Unies
après mon diagnostic,
en travaillant pendant deux ans en Angola,
un pays se relevant après 27 ans de guerre civile brutale.
Cependant, il se passa encore cinq ans
avant que je n'annonce officiellement mon diagnostic à mon employeur.
Car j'avais peur
qu'il puisse questionner ma capacité à diriger et que je perde mon travail.
Je travaillais dans des pays où la polio était courante,
alors quand j'ai entendu par hasard
quelqu'un qui pensait que j'avais sûrement survécu à la polio,
j'ai pensé que mon secret était bien gardé.
Personne ne m'a demandé pourquoi je boitais.
Donc je n'ai rien dit.
Ça m'a pris plus de dix ans
pour accepter la sévérité de l'HIBM,
même lorsque des tâches et des fonctions basiques devinrent de plus en plus dures.
Pourtant, j'ai poursuivi mon rêve de travailler dans le monde entier
et j'ai même été nommée à une antenne handicap
pour l'UNICEF à Haïti,
où j'ai travaillé deux ans,
après le tremblement de terre dévastateur de 2010.
Puis mon travail m'a menée aux États-Unis.
Et même si la maladie progressait de façon significative
et que j'avais besoin d'une attelle et d'un déambulateur,
j'attendais toujours avec hâte de nouvelles aventures.
Et cette fois-ci,
j'ai commencé à rêver d'une grande aventure en plein air.
Et qu'est-ce qui est plus grand que le Grand Canyon ?
Savez-vous que sur cinq millions de personnes qui visitent la Rive
seulement 1% descend dans l'antre du canyon ?
Je voulais faire partie de ces 1%.
Il faut savoir -
(Applaudissements)
Il faut savoir que le Grand Canyon n'est pas vraiment accessible.
J'allais avoir besoin d'être aidée
pour descendre les 1 500 mètres d'un terrain friable et vertical.
Quand je suis face à des obstacles, la peur ne s'installe pas immédiatement,
parce que je suppose que d'une manière ou d'une autre,
je trouverai une solution.
Et dans ce cas, je me suis dit que,
puisque je ne peux pas descendre,
je pourrais apprendre à monter à cheval.
C'est donc je que j'ai fait.
Et c'est après cette décision sans retour
qu'a commencé un engagement de quatre ans,
jonglant entre peur et courage
pour entreprendre une expédition de 12 jours.
Quatre jours à cheval pour traverser le Grand Canyon de rive en rive
et huit jours de rafting pour parcourir les 241 kilomètres du Colorado
avec toute une équipe de tournage avec nous.
Attention, spoiler : on a réussi.
Mais pas sans me montrer comment ma plus grande peur
peut parfois refléter un courage égal.
Le 13 avril 2018,
assise à deux mètres et demi du sol,
chevauchant un mustang appelé Sheriff,
ma première impression du Grand Canyon
a été celle de l'effroi.
Qui aurait pensé que j'avais le vertige.
(Rires)
Mais il n'était plus question de renoncer.
J'ai rassemblé chaque once de courage en moi
afin de ne pas laisser ma peur m'envahir.
En embarquant pour la Rive Sud,
tout ce que je pouvais faire pour rester calme
était de respirer profondément, regarder les nuages
et me concentrer sur les voix de mon équipe.
Mais au cours de la première heure, un désastre arriva.
Étant incapable de me tenir droite sur ma selle,
en descendant une marche surdimensionnée,
j'ai basculé en avant et me suis cognée sur l'arrière de la tête du cheval.
C'était la panique,
j'avais terriblement mal à la tête
mais le passage était trop étroit pour descendre de cheval.
Ce n'est seulement qu'à mi-chemin à 700 mètres,
au moins deux heures plus tard,
que nous avons pu nous arrêter et retirer mon casque
et voir la bosse de la taille d'un œuf qui sortait de mon front.
Avec toute cette organisation et cet équipement,
pourquoi n'avions-nous pas un seul pain de glace ?
(Rires)
Heureusement pour nous tous, l'œdème a diminué
et s'est déversé sur mon visage en deux magnifiques yeux au beurre noir,
ce qui est une manière incroyable d'apparaître dans un documentaire.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Ce ne fut une journée ni facile, ni reposante
et pourtant, c'était exactement le but.
Même si j'avais peur de remonter à cheval,
j'y suis retournée.
Rien que la descente vers la base du Grand Canyon
a pris au total 10 heures
et c'était seulement le premier de quatre jours de randonnée à cheval.
Vinrent ensuite les puissants rapides.
Le Colorado dans le Grand Canyon
possède certaines des plus hautes « eaux blanches » du pays.
Et afin d'être préparés au cas où nous chavirerions,
on m'a entraînée à nager dans un rapide plus petit.
Et je peux vous dire sans risque que ce n'était pas glamour.
(Rires)
J'ai respiré au mauvais endroit de la vague,
j'ai bu la tasse,
et j'étais incapable de me diriger.
Oui, c'était à la fois effrayant
et fantastique.
Les chutes d'eau, les canyons glissants
et des roches de quelques milliards d'années
qui changeaient de couleur dans la journée.
Le grand Canyon possède une nature sauvage
et est digne de tous ses éloges.
(Applaudissements)
L'expédition,
toute cette organisation et le voyage en lui-même,
m'ont montré un niveau de peur que je n'avais jamais connu auparavant.
Mais plus important encore,
cela m'a montré à quel point je peux être courageuse.
Mon voyage dans le Grand Canyon n'a pas été facile.
Ce n'était pas la vision d'une Amazone
se frayant un chemin sans effort à travers des paysages épiques.
Je pleurais,
épuisée et abattue avec deux yeux au beurre noir.
C'était effrayant,
stressant,
exaltant.
Une fois le voyage terminé,
c'est facile d'être « blasée » au sujet de ce que nous avons accompli.
Je sais que je veux de nouveau faire du rafting.
Cette fois-ci, parcourir les 446 kilomètres.
(Applaudissements)
Mais je sais aussi que je ne referai plus jamais la partie à cheval.
(Rires)
C'est simplement trop dangereux.
Et c'est là où je veux en venir.
Je ne suis pas ici seulement pour vous montrer mon reportage.
Je suis ici pour nous rappeler à tous
que la vie n'est pas juste une leçon
pour trouver l'équilibre entre la peur et le courage.
Et comprendre ce qui est une bonne idée et ce qui ne l'est pas.
(Rires)
La vie est suffisamment effrayante,
donc pour que nos rêves deviennent réalité, nous devons être courageux.
En affrontant mes peurs
et en trouvant le courage d'aller jusqu'au bout,
je peux affirmer que ma vie a été extraordinaire.
Alors vivez en grand,
et essayez de laisser votre courage l'emporter sur votre peur.
Vous ne savez jamais où cela peut vous mener.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)